he is advocating for biological men
trans women to be allowed to compete in
the women's division so i am a semi-pro
athlete in england i played three sports
in college why are the same men that
advocate for women's rights women's
rights to chew saying we don't have the
right to our own division men that
shouldn't have a say in this anyway does
does he look like he plays sports are
advocating for the end of women's sport
if they continue to let trans women
biological men compete in the women's
division
it will be the end of women's sports
you're going to keep seeing
men breaking women's records and if it's
so equal why don't the trans
men so biological women that are
competing in the men's division why
aren't they shattering men's records why
is it only one way and guys these are
smart people that think you need to
study to know this i don't need to study
to know that men have a biological
advantage over women even after a year
of hormone replacement men and
non-athletes need to stop speaking for
women because we don't stand for this
this is not okay